hey everybody it's Mike frieder here
with on-call compliance Solutions and
I'm back with another compliance tip of
the week this week we're talking about
cmmccontrolat.l2-3.2.1 ensure that
managers system administrators and users
of organizational systems are made aware
of the security risks associated with
their activities and of the applicable
policies standards and procedures
related to the security of those systems
[Music]
all right
so hey if you're a defense contractor
who's feeling overwhelmed tired and
alone trying to understand all of this
cmmc dfars and nist SP 800 171
compliance stuff on top of an already
colossal workload well I've got great
news for you you found your home here at
on-call compliance Solutions we can help
you transform into your company's
on-call compliance Hero Let's jump into
it so in cmfc control
at.l1-3.2.1 ensure that managers system
administrators and users of
organizational systems are made aware of
the security risks associated with their
activities and of the applicable
practices excuse me policies standards
and procedures related to the security
of those systems look this controls all
about training and awareness all right
again especially if if defense is not
the primary place you come from the goal
is to make sure your people are aware of
and trained on what it takes to keep
information secure in your organization
which is much different uh you know than
just sort of working in Normal
commercial businesses without these
requirements so again the fact that
you're becoming a defense contract or
you are a defense contractor and you've
got security as a core tenant of your
business that if that's a New Concept
this is the control they really should
call out the need to properly make
people wear and train so let's check out
what the assessors are looking for on
this one and see how to make them happy
uh again four major assessment points
here looking at at.l2 Dash 2 uh Dash
3.2.1 uh first we're going to determine
if security risks Associated
organizational activities involving cui
are identified so one are the security
risks that are going to you know be net
new to us are those identify uh if I was
to give a sample answer to an assessor I
would say hey look the organization
identifies these risks during the I
don't know let's say a quarterly risk
management activity meeting and of
course you can see our standard
operating procedure for a quarterly risk
management meeting to demonstrate that
yes they've been identified called out
we're addressing those risks uh and
we've got a documented way of doing that
now if you don't have a quarterly risk
management policy I'm going to tell you
what uh it doesn't matter if you do a
quarterly semi-annual annual again it's
requisite with the size of your company
if you don't even know what a risk
management policy looks like
okay that might be a good indication
that you could use a little bit of help
with this that's kind of what we do so
links in the bio below uh but ultimately
you're going to need a risk management
policy in place to be able to pass
assessment now Point number two
determinative policy standards and uh
procedures related security of the
system are identified so now the
question is do we have policies are they
identified are there standards and are
the procedures to manage risk are they
all identify now in our case because we
do have a quarterly risk management
policy in place we can just simply say
hey look go look at the quarterly risk
management policy right uh or your
standard operating procedures so again
it's easy when you have a policy in
place you're going to be fumbling around
for answers this control if there isn't
a policy in place
now assessment Point number three
determine if managers system
administrators and users of the system
are made aware of the security risks
associated with their activities now
this is a little bit different right so
one we can still look back at our
quarterly risk management sop because
that's a good place to kind of locate
some of that documentation but in
addition we always want all users that
are coming into contact with cui to be
trained uh using the mandatory cui
training against free trained DOD puts
out or again if you want a more
digestible version your uh that your
employees will love uh again talk to us
about our virtual compliance officer
train where we basically put on a much
easier to digest cartoonized uh uh
mandatory cui training type version so
again there are lots and lots of ways to
go about this but training is the
primary way to make people aware of the
risks now assessment Point number four
determine if managers system
administrators and users of the system
are made aware of applicable policy
standards and procedures related to the
security of a system yes see the
quarterly risk management report again
right we're still going back there we're
still going back to training right
because we're saying hey look to those
people who are in security sensitive
positions and the user of the system are
they made aware of the applicable policy
standards and procedures so have they
been treating your policies now not
necessarily the dod's mandatory cui
training so again all of that comes
together with training awareness it's
really a big deal and that's honestly
what the at group of controls is all
about now uh if you are struggling to
figure this out if you need policies
that are done for you if you just want
this whole compliance thing done for you
the good news is we here at on call work
with defense contractors just like you
who have been who have had this dfars
nist itar and cmfc compliant stuff
dropped in their lap like a single on a
sunny day we teach you how to level up
and be a proper on-call compliance hero
for your company eliminating gaps gray
areas and getting this solved all while
showing you how to leverage compliances
your secret weapon to land more Defense
work with higher profit margins now
that's what becoming an on-call
compliance hero can do for you if you're
looking for more help getting compliant
our compliance experts are always on
call for you you can visit
cmmccompliance secrets.com or you can
check out the bio below for links to
help let you get help right now and if
you love the content we're putting out
uh here for you help us out with a big
thumbs up on that like button or even
better smash the Subscribe button to get
the latest compliance content as soon as
our compliance nerves roll it out until
the next compliance tip my friends stay
safe and secure out there and hit us in
the comments below to let you let us
know what you'd like to know more about
when it comes to information security
and compliance and I'll see you on the
next one
thank you
[Music]
anyway